brace brace brace
hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report man things are looking
weird stacy right i like to call this
a blizzard dream we don't know whether
there's
inflation deflation hyperinflation
hyper deflation many of our guests say
it's inflation
and it's heading for hyperinflation
others say it's deflation is going to
head
to hyper deflation or it's deflation and
heading to hyperinflation
so we saw similar when in our early days
of kaiser report
during the last financial crisis and i
think
it's the same sort of thing today and
one of these days
one of these boom and bust cycles will
collapse the whole system
that's my opinion whether or not it's
this we don't know so we're going to
look at the
information everybody knows that house
prices are soaring out of control in
america across america
it's it's amusing to watch your house
price theoretically go up
two three four five thousand dollars
every day uh used car prices
as wolf richter said on a recent episode
here that uh consumers are willing to
pay
the increase that he as a former auto
dealer in that sector
like he's never seen anything like this
nor have any of his contacts
and that's the most important thing
according to the central bank and
inflation
is whether or not consumers are willing
to pay those increases
and prices right they don't step away
there's
they keep on demanding the product even
though it's going up in price
and stock markets of course continue to
hit a new all-time high so that's the
inflation side
then we have the deflation side of the
derivatives that there are unknown
quantities out there
well let me explain everything go ahead
in 2008 global financial crisis
we had a global credit freeze global
economy
suffered cardiac arrest effectively died
in response that's called deflation
when uh when you have a an event where
bonds for example become
worthless and they uh
you would call that deflation and in
response
the central banks flooded the system
with
money fiat money and they lowered
interest rates to zero
and this has caused a lot of bubbles
and because we live in a financialized
world
where everything is traded and
everything's commodified and
commoditized and traded on exchange
those bubbles can appear everywhere
including
food and energy occasionally so
a lot of that bubble is in food prices
and it goes up and people say ah look
inflation
but it'll be a bubble in food within the
context
of a secular deflationary collapse
the reason i can say that with some
confidence is that
we have not seen any bubble in wages
right everything is subject to a bubble
except wages because there's there is no
actual
inflation as defined by an accelerated
economic activity or business cycle
that would precipitate things like
rising interest rates rising wages et
cetera no we have
structural collapse we have
lots of money printing to faster than
the system can collapse for every
trillion dollars in bonds that are a
threat of collapsing the central banks
will inject five trillion worth of fiat
money
and the interest rates are near zero and
those who can the speculators and those
are now the ruling elites of the world
are the speculator kings
they can create bubbles it could be used
cars this week it could be
food next week it could be islands
somewhere in the pacific the week after
that those are bubbles within a secular
collapse
and ultimately when the everything
bubble collapses then we have
the realization that the economy died
in 2008 we just haven't buried it yet
right and that wage
inflation story is entered into in this
jpmorgan report recently where they're
predicting
three percent inflation for the next 10
years they're outside
their peer group say jpmorg goldman
sachs thinks it's not going to hit 2
percent
at all over the next 10 years but there
jp morgan's predicting it's going to run
higher
and it's obviously not because of wages
wages are not going up
but their income is going up the
ordinary americans income has gone up
dramatically in the past year because of
all the stimulus
all of the enhanced unemployment
benefits
all of that has caused their wages to go
up americans unleashing pent-up savings
could drive up inflation and rattle
parts of the market jp morgan's chief
strategist says karen ward said in an
online presentation this week that jp
morgan estimates
americans have built up extra savings
worth around eight percent of u.s gdp
during the covet 19 pandemic when their
spending options have been limited
war a former top economic adviser to the
uk's finance ministry said she thought
most of this would be unleashed in a
spending spree when combined with joe
biden's 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
bill worth around 9
of gdp that is likely to push inflation
higher she said right as you point out
that's not
those aren't wages no that's income so
the income through transfer payments yes
through money printing
yeah because the economy died in 2008
and it's being
kept animated like you an animated
corpse with
electric shocks uh with money printing
and this is causing
bubbles so used car prices are in a
bubble not because wages are growing and
that there's inflation and there's gdp
growth and there's any
hope of paying down the national debt
those hopes have been
dashed that's never going to happen but
we do have these bubbles within the
collapsing global economy
and the acceleration of that crash is
increasing
which is now contributing to
geopolitical tensions
uh you know you've got this new cold war
situation bubbling
that's because the economy died in 2008.
though it just dawned on me when you
said
the transfer payments it could just be a
situation whereby
you know you talk about the geopolitical
tensions and we've talked about the
thucydides trap and that the conflict
emerges when a rising power overtakes a
declining power
you know that happened to europe in the
past as well so
you know we could just be coming
becoming more french
like you know more and more people you
know there's
mass deflation across europe as well
there's a deflationary problem there
but you know because wages aren't rising
wages don't go up
but there's huge transfer payments from
the government it seems like markets
accept that in some way though jp morgan
does point out that this the
the opening the first quarter to 2021
has been the worst bond market
since the 80s so they they're suggesting
that's the bond market
thinking there's going to be uh pricing
in huge inflation
so right well the bond signals on the
30-year
bond uh clearly shows a downward trend
it's currently two percent yield on the
30-year
and there's room for it to go to 0.25
25 basis points so we'll see about that
in the next nine months if
u.s is becoming more like french then
the switch psychologically
in america you work to take time off and
in
france you take time off and work is
something that just
allows you to take more time off right
it's a completely different psychology
we've lived there for many years we know
how that goes
uh in the u.s you get two weeks vacation
and many americans don't take the full
two weeks
in france you get eight or nine weeks
vacation and that can be stretched out
to
12 or 13 or 14 weeks vacation and that's
the psychology
is that work as a necessary evil to take
time off
well again the psychology changes and
that's the thing that uh
central banks in particular worry about
and investors
so we have as we mentioned like you have
transfer payments that were huge last
year
and whether or not you know a biden
administration will be able to
roll that back it's unlikely right once
you're getting all that free money who
wants to take a 20
cut in their pay you know their income
essentially
and michael bury the famous hedge fund
manager
who is a subject of the movie the big
short who shorted the housing market
when the subprime mortgage market
collapsed and caused a global financial
crisis
well remember he said that we're in the
beginning
or the end of the weimar stage like the
end is the
last year of hyperinflation so he's
saying you know it went for nine or ten
years and you saw a lot of inflation and
a lot of like booming stock markets and
booming property markets as
as the investors the psychology was
changing over those 10 years getting
ready for
more and more inflation until it
collapses their whole faith in it
investors have put more money into
stocks in the last five months
than the previous 12 years combined in
raw numbers
569 billion dollars has flowed into
global equity funds since november
compared with 452 billion going back to
the beginning of the 2009-2020 bull
market
again obviously there's somebody on the
other side selling it
to these investors but a lot of people
are flush with a lot of cash but it's
also that psychology that michael bury
talks about of the weimar
you know if you can control this
inflation if you could do something if
it gets too hot
you know bran bernanke had argued they
could just stop it in a few minutes by
raising interest rates
but whether or not they could do a paul
volcker sort of situation as happened in
1980 when he ratcheted up interest rates
to near 20
we'll see no they can't and and stocks
are clearly in a bubble
and as a result of all this money
printing transfer payments and ease
of access through apps like robinhood
and others you've got
folks who are getting money from the
government and going right into stock
market speculation
and buying options and going on margin
and the margin
uh pool has never been higher not even
before the crash of 1929 did you see as
much margin
on a percent basis than you do right now
it's the highest percent
based margin fueled stock market ever in
history
and again that is a function of a bubble
within a collapsing system
when those bubbles start bursting pop
pop pop pop
um then you have
the recipe for a global conflict sadly
because
there will be no way for one country to
survive without taking the resources of
another country
well we see that in this final headline
here from bloomberg
and in terms of you know great
depression sort of
uh times and blizzard dreams of of
negative rates and negative oil prices
and
and crazy stock signals price signals
and stuff like that
well um we've always had a beggar thy
neighbor right everybody
every nation of course tries to survive
the best they can and
that includes the weapon of beggaring
thy neighbor and if you have the us
dollar as a reserve currency if you get
to print it then
you can export inflation or import
inflation whichever one you choose
the global middle class shrank last year
for the first
time since the 1990s with about 150
million people
slipping down the economic ladder so
this is a new
study out and it shows that 150 million
people
tumbled out of the middle class right so
the
the rise in the bubbles like the stock
market are masking the fact that the
global middle class is shrinking
it's neo feudalism as we've called it
before it's this barbell economy where
it's extreme concentration
of uber wealth at the very tippity top
and everyone else is essentially hand to
mouth
and one paycheck away or one transfer
payment away from
being homeless and there's absolutely
nothing in the middle
and that's by design by the way because
oligarchs love to oligarch
you know yeah it's interesting that the
lockdown of the economies is really
exposing
that layer of the cantillon effect i
mean we do have a real economy that
manufactures stuff and creates wealth
but the the financialized economy has
grown bigger and bigger and starting to
swamp that real economy and you really
see it that's the heightened
exaggeration of that cantillon effect
when all there is is essentially
money printing for most of the world
outside of
you know china yeah the financialization
as a component of the economy
for 30 years now has grown every single
year and i think it's
it's well over 70 percent now if you
make all the correct adjustments anyway
we're going to take a break and when we
come back much more coming your way
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser let's go to alice mcleod of
goldmoney.com
i'm an investor in the company alastair
welcome back
nice to be back max let's talk about
inflation deflation hyperinflation
hyper deflation what's the current
thinking
well i think the first thing we need to
do is define
inflation and deflation inflation is
simple
it is an increase in the quantity of
money in circulation
deflation is not so simple because it's
something that
very rarely happens and overall it
hasn't happened in our lifetimes
um what you would look at for deflation
would be a contraction
in the quantity of money the effect on
prices is
is is is in effect but the real
deflation would be a contraction in the
total quantity of money we haven't seen
that
now i know a lot of people talk about
deflation but what they're really
talking about
is they see prices may be falling
but that hasn't happened either i mean
the the uh prices were falling
in the first uh month or so
of uh 2020 before the fed stepped in
in march march the 19th cut the fed
funds rate from one half down to
zero and then the following monday
announced 120 billion
monthly qe and a few other bits and
pieces
so that was that was if you like for the
deflationists the last
deflationary time now having said that
the majority of the money that is
created is actually created by the
commercial banks
not the fed it's important to understand
that
why are the banks creating uh money well
in the last year they haven't created
that much they have created roughly four
percent
i looked at the figures earlier and i
can see that total bank
credit uh up until the end of march was
standing at
15.247 trillion
a year ago it was at 14.694
trillion so what have they been doing
with it there are three things they can
do
they can either puff up asset prices
they can lend it to consumers or they
can lend it to business
now the omnibus figure for business
lending
and uh to an extent also consumer
lending we will take as the loans and
leasing total
that actually decreased from 10 trillion
681 billion
uh it decreased from that to
10 trillion 329 billion now that's a
fall of about three percent so what were
they doing with the balance the answer
basically is that they were investing in
securities
in other words they were puffing up the
markets
so we have an inflation of prices in
uh non-fixed interest securities markets
we now also have inflation if you like
all
the effects of inflation falling
purchasing power for the dollar
in commodities and also of course crypto
assets and to a lesser extent
gold and silver so we are in
inflationary times it's as simple as
that
it is possible that the commercial banks
will reduce their bank credit but
actually if you look at the amount of
money there is in the system
i mean this is just it just crazy total
bank credit is standing at over 15
trillion
m1 the narrow money supply is
18.4 trillion this in other words
there's more money in the system
than there is bank credit um it's
just an extraordinary situation so
it is inflationary and uh how it affects
prices depends really on how that
is translated if you like into is it is
it aimed at the consumer
this is a good good example because the
expansion of
consumer spending obviously drives up
prices
other things being equal what you have
is a government which is drawn down on
its general account
to helicopter money into every um
bank account of everybody who earns less
than a hundred thousand dollars
they've also increased the amount of uh
welfare payments uh for the unemployed
and so on now what this does is it just
pushes money
first into savings and then as the lock
down
uh um uh ceases
that is likely to dribble back into
spending but again
it's not going to um be satisfied by an
increase in production
so you can see that the end prices will
drive will be
driven up so i think it's the it's it's
the biden
um helicoptering of money
which is probably the greatest effects
on rising prices
translating monetary inflation into
price inflation at the moment
alastair if there's inflation what
happens to the price
of bonds not the yield but what happens
to the price
of bonds during inflation
quite simply they fall which is why so
my
follow-up question would be i'm looking
at the 30-year treasury
bond and it's done nothing but go up
so there's not there's something wrong
with this picture let me ask you this
it seems that in 2008 we had this huge
credit freeze the global economy
came to a screeching halt it was a
massive effort by central planners the
central bankers to refloat
the economy with a massive injection
of money of fiat money
and that fiat money is sloshing around
the system in the form of bubbles we see
bubbles in commodities we see bubbles on
the stock market we see
bubbles across the spectrum and
this leads some to conclude
that we have some inflation but
the overall the arc of history from
2008 to today and going back even
further
is this fall in yield
a rise in bond prices
which is the classic view of
deflation number one and number two if
you've got this inflation
how come there's no wage inflation right
so there's two key indicators that tell
me that the
big picture is deflation and within that
we've got bubbles from all the money
that you rightly point out there's a
huge there's
trillions and trillions of dollars and
because interest rates are at zero
percent
and because there's no accountability
and there's no enforcement of financial
regulations
that bubble of cash is moving about and
it creates distortions
and it creates bubbles but that's not
necessarily
the predominant theme one could call
inflation
alistair well it goes back to what i was
saying about
where is the bank credit going it is not
going into
the economy it is not going into
industry
it is going into non-fixed interest
securities and fixed interest securities
as far as the banks are concerned the
safest thing of the lot
of course is u.s treasuries now i
haven't been following the
30-year bond yield as closely as you
obviously have
but i can tell you that the yield on the
10-year treasury
has actually risen quite steeply in
recent months
it's a little bit off the top now but
we're talking about something which uh
in february uh the yield was just under
one percent it's now what 1.66
that's a reasonable rise in yield which
basically means a reasonable fall if you
like in the price of the 10-year
treasury
now not only that but you have to bear
in mind
foreign ownership of dollars that is
standing at approximately
28 trillion dollars which compares with
the gdp
of roughly 20 21 trillion dollars
so the foreigners are they own an
awful lot of dollars and guess where
they are they are in
u.s treasuries they are in cash i think
about uh
six and a half trillion of that is
sitting in bank deposits and
um short-term instruments such as ust
bills
on top of that um you have got
investments portfolio investments in
in the stock market now they are
important because
the first people who will feel sensitive
to a fall in the purchasing power of the
currency
are foreign owners of it and they will
demand a higher return in order to
stay with that currency so we are likely
to see
increasing market pressure on the fed um
which means that um they will be
fighting to
keep um the uh short-term overnight
rates uh
at close to the zero bond now this is
important because
either the fed responds by raising rates
or
the dollar tanks i mean it's it's it's
really a binary choice it's as simple as
that
that's true you know you've got the u.s
dollar world reserve currency
but the if there was uh
again when you started and you said we
need to have a definition for inflation
and a definition for deflation
and this you know in different uh minds
can can
mean different things um clearly
when you've got an economy where the
employment participation rate in the u.s
is at some of the lowest numbers we've
seen in decades
where um the gdp is
uh suffering as a result small to medium
enterprises are going out of business
the the central banks are are printing
all this money to try to stimulate
the economy because and they say you
know they're fighting deflation
now but the result is
within a crashing economy let me let me
put it to you this way because we've had
this conversation a few times
is there another something maybe we need
to consider here
it's not really inflation or deflation
it what it what what if this is just a
massive power grab by the central banks
who know
that their policies are not working as
as indicated
and but it is making the oligarchs at
the top
of all the countries they made trillions
of dollars
is this not alistair i'll put it to you
this way a little creative thinking here
is this not almost you could call it
neo-feudalism
i think that's actually quite a good
description because i mean
you know all of us are serfs in this um
environment
i mean the policy makers and the policy
planners in the central banks
um you know they are going on a course
which basically
funds the government and enriches the
banks
why does it enrich the banks because
there is a transfer a wealth transfer
from money printing
from you me everybody else into the
banks and into the government
and um we lose out now this is
never ever admitted by uh the policy
planners
instead what they do is they say we're
creating a wealth effect
because what they do is qe and the qe is
targeted at
pension funds and insurance funds um
pension funds insurance funds sell
government
debt treasuries to the fed and
the fed gives them cash through the
banking system which puffs up the
bank's reserves i mean that's just a
balance sheet effect
and the pension funds and the insurance
funds are encouraged
to to invest in riskier assets and so
you get money going into corporate debt
and you get money going into
um into into the stock market into into
ordinary stocks
and that is the bubble so right on one
hand
they have the central banks are saying
we are creating a wealth effect
but on the other hand they're taking it
away from us through inflation
and the people who are suffering are the
low paid
the people who can't respond to this
situation
of the purchasing power of their wages
and their pensions and their savings
being taken away from them they can't
respond
but as you rightly say the people who
really benefit
are the people who are in the system the
rich
the people who um have set up these
enormous companies
you know the bill gates of this world
and so on so forth so that is why you've
got this divide actually happening
and it's extraordinary all right we're
going to carry this over to a second
segment ouster
and we're getting somewhere finally
after years
thanks for being on this kaiser report
thanks thanks very much for having me
okay and that's going to do it for this
edition of kaiser report with me max
kaiser and stacy herbert want to thank
our guest alice mcleod until next time
bye y'all
[Music]